you
anterior ankle fusion is an open
surgical procedure that fuses or joins
the ankle bones together
the ankle is the joint that connects the
leg in the foot the ankle joint includes
the two lower leg bones called the tibia
and the fibula and the ankle bone called
the talus together the ends of the tibia
and fibula create a mortise or slot for
the talus which forms the bottom of the
ankle joint tissues called ligaments and
tendons support the ankle bones
ligaments attach bones to bones and
tendons attach muscles to bones the
ankle joint allows the foot to move up
and down articular cartilage on the ends
of bones is a smooth gliding covering
that allows fluid joint movement
ankle fusion also known as arthrodesis
is a surgical procedure that joins the
ankle bones together so they no longer
move or rub against each other doctors
may recommend this procedure for
conditions that lead to severe ankle
joint damage and pain the most common
condition is osteoarthritis also known
as degenerative joint disease in the
late stage of osteoarthritis cartilage
covering the ends of the bones has worn
away exposing bare bone this along with
the growth of bony projections called
bone spurs causes swelling pain and
limited movement of the joints another
condition that may require ankle fusion
is rheumatoid arthritis where the
patient's own immune system attacks the
joints any condition that destroys the
joint surface such as a severe bone
infection or death of bone tissue called
osteonecrosis may also require fusion of
the ankle joint
the procedure will begin with an
incision on the front or anterior part
of the ankle next the surgeon will open
up the ankle to see inside the joint
space between the tibia and tailless
bones damaged cartilage and bone will be
removed from the bottom surface of the
tibia this will also be done to the top
surface of the talus then the surgeon
will attach the bones to each other with
screws
or with a metal plate and screws
bone tissue may be taken from an area
such as the patient's pelvic bone or
upper tibia or it may come from a bone
Bank this will be used as bone graft to
fill the joint space and help the bones
grow together finally the skin incision
will be closed with stitches after the
ankle fusion the patient will no longer
be able to move the ankle joint
however fusion removes the pain caused
by arthritic surfaces rubbing together
and other joints in the foot continue to
allow limited movement